all right Charlie
uh where are you from where'd you grow
up so I grew up in boy lights which is
like the first little area just outside
of downtown going east yeah just that
way just right over the bridge a few
miles two miles away tell me about your
family growing up
well I'm an only child so uh no siblings
whatsoever uh it was just my mom my mom
and I my mom left my dad when I was two
because she saw that he was not going to
be a proper male figure role model
uh for me so even then she was looking
out for my best interest I mean to where
she'd be located so
she moved from here oddly enough which
was sixth in San Pedro in 84. oh she
lived down yeah they lived right here
and then I headed out to Boyle Heights
um she moved in with like some other
women
um and so that's where I grew up
primarily then uh moved a very few times
but always within a one block
proximity so I stayed within the same
area you know same school
um but uh family was a big thing for me
because it was the one thing that I
locked the most I felt and uh like I
wasn't privileged to have a
a family unit as I called it a mom dad
brother sister you know housekeeper dog
neighbor your dad was out of the picture
yeah well he was in so in my mom's a
naivety I mean
she once said I can't teach you to be a
man so you know only your father cancer
she always spoke well with him even
though they separated because she knew
he was my dad so she would take me to
him and drop me off at his place on
weekends every now and then but my dad I
mean she didn't know any better she was
naive
she thought she was doing the best I
mean she met well and so my dad was like
a he was an alcoholic you know he drank
did a lot of Coke
you know but he was my my God my hero so
um I would see him like on weekends
maybe one or two weekends out of the
week of the month perhaps
at most
um
but that's also why I was first
introduced to drugs
like my dad out of the lips somewhere he
lived with his buddies up here somewhere
and uh I remember him distinctly saying
oh grab Charlie and take him into the
other room
and so of course I ran back as soon as
his buddy let me go because I want to
see what my dad was doing and what I now
know is cocaine I thought he was smoking
salt off the table I was like eight
years old
however when I got home I got salt and
chopped it up with a razor blade just
like my dad dude and snorted up my nose
just like my dad dude and went running
to my mom crying because my nose was
bleeding seeing why didn't my dad cry
why am I crying
and I just remembered that
yeah the fascination of a drug
fascination with drugs yeah but yeah
but you know family that was uh
that was the one thing that uh I wish I
had most
of when did you start using
so I started using
I wouldn't even say habitually but the
first time I used I
tried was like at 10 years old I smoked
like a roach
of marijuana but I spit it out because I
can't do this enough I can't do this to
my mom and I threw it away which is
really intriguing you know looking in
hindsight I actually had that willpower
and the thought of my mother to not to
not use but once I hit like 13 I started
smoking pot
and I fell in love with it
it was about 13 or 14. habitual user by
14 I believe
mostly pot just pot that's all it was
um but then growing up I you know I grew
up in Boyle Heights and back in those
days the predominant drugs were pot you
know stress you know cocaine and that
and uh
heroin although I never really saw it
but I saw a lot of crackheads
and uh so it was easily accessible to do
cocaine so that started hitting the
picture once you had more friends as you
had older like it always it came in the
picture
but again see back in those days I was
also into punk rock I was into the east
alley underground punk rock scene so on
weekends I'd go off and do gigs and went
on or I'd either participate in playing
a gig or I just go and hang out and get
drunk and coked out of my mind so I
became a weekend warrior at a very early
age I look at now like 15 16 years old
high school you know doing well somewhat
you know I wasn't applying to myself
when I was getting by
but on the weekends I just partied
and then I first tried speed in 10th
Grade
and when I when I tried it like it was I
felt so I felt like God I felt I felt
like I could take on the world like I
had no one security whatsoever
and uh
but then I had never found that again
and the drugs thing is it's it's weird
though because when I'm sober I'm a
completely different person
I'm the same person however my likes and
interests are far different from when
I'm getting loaded
but when I'm getting loaded it's like I
realize that drugs are non-confidence
have taken up a significant part of my
life how old are you now I just turned
41 in May 31 which is nuts you're 41.
I'm 41. you look you look 23. I like
shot out is what I look like thank you
no I I'm a
when I'm sober I love going to the gym
and uh I'm usually like you know maybe
10 pounds bigger muscular wise
I love bodybuilding and stuff but I
think Haggard and old now but thank you
though I mean I think I got my first
gray hair on my chin
so what are you using now
uh methane heroin
yeah
I've been here when it's been like that
for uh for some time
um
and you're living on the streets
I am so every time I get loaded every
time I relapse
I uh
I create this great
beginning great job great potential you
know you know the same story you hear
all the time and then I I all I want to
do is just get drunk one night and just
do one goofball one mixed syringe full
of methane heroin just to feel that ah
and uh I wind up binging but mostly back
here and the reason I started coming
here as a kid was because since my
grandmother's bar was up the street and
as a kid growing up it was like you know
I I was Jaded by the by all this so but
I knew no one I knew would ever dare
come here so no one could find me here
so I can get loaded on the street and
then you know the next dates go what's
going through your head when you're
clean
and you relapse like you know it's going
to take you down
but you do it anyway
I've gone over this a thousand times
I've had psychiatrists I've had
counselors
is
I it's not the Romancing or glamorizing
of the drug use or the euphoric recall
that gets me loaded
I always wind up setting myself up to
where there's one event or one situation
or one person a woman to where something
happens and I can't take it anymore and
I get so hung up and so depressed
I just want to numb out that pain
you know
and so
before
I think before I added there was so much
psychological
such a psychological variable to it
before it was just more like I didn't
want to get high yeah I probably should
no I'd rather not because of those
consequences
but see now I think I I think I I put
the blame on myself because I'm the only
one to blame but
I play so much emotional
uh pain
to prior to my relapse is that it seems
like that's exactly why I relapse
but uh
I'm in so much emotional pain that I say
[__] it
you know I used to say just as long as
you just don't stick a needle with a
needle in your arm or just don't go past
this weekend
it's crazy though because
you know I'm not one to just use
for months on Android years on end I
start up you know everyone loves helping
everyone sees that I try and I really do
I was silver two and a half years before
I relapsed you know I had my daughter I
was two and a half years yeah AAA
sponsoring everything
and I've always gone back to meetings
but uh
do you think it's
you know the the pain of some emotional
thing that you went through as a child
or is it just that you you inherited
your dad's DNA that's the thing and this
is why
initially in the beginning I always
thought well you know I had I had a you
know I don't think any event makes me an
alcoholic
and I used to say I had these are just
the cards that worked out that I was
dealt with and so you know mostly when
asicada was like the fact that I was
alone I was alone
so much as a kid and and I put so much
emphasis on that because uh it hurts so
bad just to be alone and as a kid you
know that it looks like
normal you know image you have as of a
child in their childhood is a family and
it you know someone to talk to just
when it wasn't where I was
and so
I used to think that it was because of
those reasons that I got loaded and then
I realized no you know it's not bad just
I I thought of far too long I've tried
to figure out why I drank and used yeah
I just [__] ran around in circles
but I think for the mo now I just really
sit and think as to whether or not I do
it because I just want to do it and I
don't care but
how can I not care
like
like I think I did the worst thing I
could have ever done
May 30th
what was that I I
my mom picked up my daughter with my me
and my mom picked up my daughter from my
her parents place and died took her back
to my mom's place I don't have my own
place so
you know fortunately I have a great
relationship with my kid and her parents
her mom and stepdad
had that weekend with my kid my mom
took her back home and then decided to
stay at my mom's place
for another night before I went back to
my cousin's place
where I was actively looking for a
treatment center
he was letting me stay there and uh my
mom said sure fine I'd love to have you
here why wouldn't you
and she goes on to work
I grabbed some meth and heroin and I I
come back
I'm getting loaded she calls maybe at 11
o'clock and I know she's gonna be home
at 3 30. and just before she gets home I
whacked out I've done way too much way
too fast
I start doing heroin and the next thing
I know is I wait I open my eyes
and I'm looking at my mom's ceiling my
mom's ceiling with like four paramedics
in front of my eyes and I'm like no no
it's this is just like on TV like I
never thought I'd do this but I said no
no Charlie this isn't happening this
isn't happening it's a [__] dream and
I'm slapping myself because I know
what's happening
but I can't believe that it's happening
like like
I can't believe that it's happening
and then I can hear my mom's like
Terror
she got home to uh her only child
[__] purple clutching something in
his hand purple
what does this do to you emotionally
yeah that's the thing is I I couldn't I
don't think I've allowed myself to
really process it
because uh
and this is where all the machine kicks
in and I think it really uh
adds to my addiction but it's like I the
disappointment I've said on my mom for
so many years it's just it's too much
for me to bear and I think this was just
like
the icing on the cake that just destroys
her
I mean you know she this is something
every any parent who has a drug addicted
child
you know fears to face as to whether or
not they're kids going to die from that
addiction my mom had to live that
but she will never forget that because I
didn't die so she's
but she'll always look back on that day
and I haven't called my mom since
out of Shame I'm a shame
but uh
and also you know once I turned 41 I
mean that's actually when I had 40 it's
like I
you know I've been relapsing about every
three to four months at that point
and now I'm just like I'm running out of
ideas as to how to stay sober
I'm 40 [__] years old I was wanting
to go to UC Santa Cruz
you know being a most likely to
succeeding
and uh
what's your biggest fear now
my biggest fear now is that I not get
sober
and then I cause more emotional and
psychological pain to my daughter
do you still have friends
always had friends I've always been that
gregarious individual I've always had a
bunch of friends and really good friends
most a lot of Normie friends because I
always want to keep myself you know
connected to the world outside of
Alcoholics Anonymous
and uh but it seems like
after this after these three years after
once this
varying this relapsed or this
whatever I want to call it
a lot of those good friends like normal
friends or uh
moving on
you know they don't get it they don't
get addiction but they uh
and all my other friends and Alcoholics
Anonymous and whatnot I mean they know
they have to move on if I'm not willing
to uh jump back on the boat
but uh
you know it's easy to see like I'm alone
it's like I I know I'm not but I know
but I kind of am but now it feels like a
there we go
it's weird
that's your biggest regret
biggest regret
I mean not having gone to school I think
because that's all I wanted to do not
because I knew it was the biggest thing
to do to have is it the most important
thing in life was a degree it wasn't
because of that because that was the
idea back in those days we're talking
about like you know
2000s you know in the 90s
but uh I just wanted to go to school
have a thirst for knowledge
you know I really wanted to uh
expand on
things I always had interests in
it's a It's that or the most important I
think which is uh
I regret having caused so much emotional
pain to the ones that love me
and I think it's because if I was like
an [__] if I was one of those people
that just ran the streets hurt people
you know was in and on Prison didn't
care
I
if I was that type of person I think it
wouldn't matter the thing was that I'm
not and so and I've always put a good
effort
and to change my life and so I'm always
a crude
a wealth of support
you seem like you're a great person you
just have this addiction problem
screws up everything
I've had some great opportunities
what would you say is your greatest
strength
I mean I want to say resilience I feel
like I'm not that resilient though
but I guess I am in the sense that I do
see and accept the fact that
regardless of how how bad a relapse
might be or or how bad I
messed up
or whatever uh
I do have the ability to say okay well
whatever let's pick ourselves up and you
know move forward and not walking around
with this like uh Badge of
disappointment but with a badge of
of
being proud of the fact that I you know
I am changing and I have the privilege
to change because when I do get sober
like I said it's like I want to take on
the world again I don't just you know
sit and
and say that my life's [__]
is there a self-destructive streak in
you yeah is that it
that's the thing is it's I'm like two
people
right
my one of my biggest fears now is this
relapse is going on for a while has gone
on for a while I've never seen it on the
street this long
I've never been to tent the relapses
tend to get you start up right exactly
where you were last time right I did I
did and you know Bill to
anything was I didn't care
because uh
I mean as long as I'm well
it's it's not it's not so much the idea
that I say well it's not so bad
it's that uh
I just think it doesn't matter
and whenever I start kicking or yeah
when I start kicking because that's been
that's gone on long enough right that I
not use
are sobering up just a tad bit
and my Silver Self starts you know uh
looking at where I'm at and how I'm
living like it freaks me out it scares
me
doesn't have to numb that out
because I've walked down here sober you
know in recovery because I have to use
the trains and the buses and I've been
like holy [__] get me out of here and
that's like in the morning or the
afternoon that's with daylight
you know and now it can be two o'clock
in the morning and I'm walking around
like nothing
here you are here I am it's not about
common sense or intelligence is it you
know everyone says intelligence is
against you when it comes to combating
addiction it's almost like the more
intelligent you are the yeah University
isn't thinking about it too much but uh
yeah I think it's probably the worst uh
disease there is
certainly frustrating
but then on a different day you can talk
to me and ask me the same questions I
mean be like yeah okay yeah I'm an
addict and I have those deficiencies but
I do have people to get silver and I'm
sober and I'm totally positive
optimistic and I'm an active you know
I'm proactive in whatever I do and
anything that I do
which is the way I'd like to be and and
I don't
get depressed
nearly as much
as uh to my life's past or what I could
have done what I didn't do
I want to get back to that
I see that I have value for people I
have value to give to people
is it a self-worth issue
I think it's a 100 self-worth issue yeah
when Abraham's right
sometimes I just think it's as simple as
that
because if you yourself worth is really
where it should be
you wouldn't allow this stuff to creep
into your life
I wouldn't allow any
idea of
any insecurity
beat me down to this
into this
because it would be inconceivable for me
to think less of myself
because I I'd be worth it
I am which is I which I am but it's like
it's an empty I am
what that implies is that
what you believe about yourself
dictates everything that's going to
happen to you
guys and that's a scary thought because
I'm wearing it on my sleeve
when I don't
typically what do you do for money when
you're down and out
so
well when I'm down and out I just try to
you know what can I do um
I thought I think about this every day
like how do I come up with money I mean
I do it's just stupid little odds and
ends just dumb little things like
take a survey or uh
do an interview yeah or like calling a
friend and you know hey do me a favor
you know this and that so I go get you
know I get dressed I shave whatever I
look as clean as I can I go over do them
a favor which takes like 20 minutes and
then it gives me 100 bucks but just
because he's a friend he's helping me
out you know but those those rep those
resources gotta get uh exhausted and so
at some point people start asking like
why do you keep asking me for
you know stuff to do to pay you you know
and so
uh that doesn't last too long one thing
I can't do I've never done really is is
Boost I'm not a I can't walk into a
Kmart or a Target and take something I
just
I'm a horrible uh Hustler
um but
usually what I do is you know I'm
working and I just save up a little
money on a couple of grand
and something happens and I relapse and
I go through all that
but uh what's been your lowest point
my lowest point
to me would be more uh
emotional I guess just the lack of uh
presence in my daughter's life
how old's your daughter she just turned
12.
that's always hard for a parent yeah um
yeah she really loves sleeping
I really love her but
I
those first three and a half years were
great I had her every other weekend
and now it's like and she said this to
me on our last visit she said you know
it seems like I speak to you and then I
won't hear from you for another three or
four months
and then you pop up again and then
that's exactly the way it's been the
last few years
Charlie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
of this
I can't answer that
in the middle of it you're in the middle
of it yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking but
I want to one day say uh
for Less anyways you want to
that people do love you because you are
worth being loved yeah I think believing
that you are worth
the love of others and
all the good fortune that can come in
your life believing you deserve that
is a huge it's a huge it sounds easy but
it's a huge step to to me
it's it's like the most basic of
ideas or or
like rudimentary ideas of just being a
whole
human
being
putting that little piece is missing
it doesn't matter how smart you are or
people think you are
I'm not I'm not a religious person but I
think that's where
God and religion and all that can
actually be really beneficial everyone
in a outside of a all my friends that
love me everyone that cares has been
saying the same thing
like I think there are messages and all
of that that can be really helpful for
somebody like you you're just not going
to hear it from me
all right thank you so much thank you I
wish you all the luck in the world man